はっはっはっはは
ふはっはっっはっは
はっはっはっはっはっは
はあ〜あ
また俺は天才なことにおもいついてしまった、
みなさん音楽を聴くとき
どうやって聞いていますか？
そう
大抵の、一般ピープルは
『イヤホン』を使って音楽を聞いていると思います
イヤホンを使えば
周りのひとの迷惑にもならないし
自分だけで音楽を聞けるという
素晴らしい代物だぁ〜
いやほん
素晴らしい素晴らしいブラビングブラビング、、、、、、、、、、、
パッパッパッパッパッパ
だが！
イヤホンで聴いている音楽は自分でしか聞こえない、
他のひとに自分が聞いている音楽は共有できないんっすよ
これは良く無い
自分だけのからに、閉じこもってちゃ
音楽の良さ素晴らしさ、感動もね
他のひとに共有できなくなるんすよ
そう音楽は共有して、なんぼなんすよ
わかるかぁ、、？
ズルっ
そう音楽はね、みんなでわかって初めて音楽なんすよっ！
僕が今回言いたいのは音がくを、共有したい！
みんなでね
音が大きいと周りのひとに迷惑なんすよ
みんなで音楽を共有しようと思うと人の迷惑になるんすよ
良く無い
ふんっ
だが私は考えた！
人に迷惑をかけず
音楽をみんなで共有する方法を！
こう言う物がございます
イヤホン端子分散ケーブル
こうゆうかんじになっています
その先にまた二つ、別れております
その先にイヤホンをさすような端子があります
これは何を意味するかというと
例えばアイホンで音楽を聴くと
また二つに分離させる
その為のケーブルです
あ〜〜さけるチーズ
こうなってるからまた端子にイヤホンをさすと
これすごいとおもいます
このイヤホンを分散させるケーブルを、今回５０個
用意しました
ふ〜っはっはっはっはっは
パーフェクト
これやばいよまじで
すごいよ
これを次々に分散させるということです
これをさっき刺したところにさせば
こう言うこと
またこうさせば
つまり俺が今日やりたいのは
アイホンからたくさん繋げて
こう枝分かれさせていくということです
たくさん枝分かれさせていって端子にまたつなげることによって
５１人で音楽を聴くことができるわけです
さらに片耳で・・・
あっ足つった
そして片耳ずつだと１００人で音楽を聴くことができるのです
イヤホンでなぁ〜
ただこれわから無いんだよこんだけイヤホンを
つけてみようと思います
これはかなり高まりから
スプリット大切さ的なこと
になりかける人の数年経った
今でも実験的な感じですが
意外と薄
ここに本意な流れと分散させ
たいと思ってますからと都が
2つ入った国語でイヤホンを
入れずにまった
そこで高分散させる技術と
子供3人で混乱回避のため
にここにわたって展開容認論
が主流になるとこれを正しく
理解していただき行為や
になる
横浜市でもや培養百人で
みんなで静かに音楽共有
できる場としても活用
できます早くも4高校4校が
本郷上で早めに外れるどんな
手を打ってくる何が何だか分
かれてきた
スッと入っていけるべき内容
につきましては市場に大量の
燃料が漏れているので
これから各端子にとって厄を
はめていきましょう山公園
背景や方向性と中印韓の時に
分
定員3人しておりますが家内
安全や豊真将のmf八反田
ドラマなんですがこのためや
をつけていきましょう
トルコは0-1の3回2死一二塁
病弱だったがわれわれは
いつでも上問題がない段階で
リリーフ陣できるエリアも
作ってみたいですけども大幅
安の反動で本当に切り替えが
できなければならないがその
上でずっとこの点を展示
できるようになっています
よねと話したが日程は約1カ
月間までは急増しているの
である
3年前からでないとすれば
自衛隊がどこであるか
分からない語った
楽天から何とか手として大事
だが音楽だけでなくなり明確
にほとんどなくなっていたか
どうかは定かではないかと
聞いていますので早速と聞
いている
聞こえるす
一方すごい
引き続き行います
なんと聞こえる
政府は本年度と来年度から
構築を行っている
スポーツポート次いで着工
から全部から外れていたと
したことで発行数は約220分筋
合意だ
もう2度としない
ast